hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast critical appraisal of
animal studies presented by dr. Annette
O'Connor we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots for more information please visit
lab routes comm I am soon fan of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we can at the end of
the presentation also please notice that
you are viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right and finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the lower right at the top
right of the presentation window or use
the human-made button to let us know
that you're having a problem now I'd
like to introduce our speaker dr.
Annette O'Connor after Hana received a
Bachelor of veterinary science from the
University of Sydney in 1993 and a
master of myth veterinary science from
the university of cleveland in 1997 and
a doctor of veterinary science from the
University of Delft in 2001 in two
thousand of nine dr. O'Connor was
admitted as a fellow of Epidemiology to
Australian and New Zealand college of
veterinary scientists cheese professor
of Epidemiology at Iowa State University
where she teaches epidemiology methods
and inference in the preventive
veterinary medicine program dr. Connor
currently works in the area of research
synthesis systematic reviews and
meta-analysis and therefore devotes a
large amount of time to critical
appraisals of studies involving animals
please join me in welcoming dr. Annette
O'Connor and I'll now turn the
presentation over to her thanks very
much for the introduction it's great to
be here um
and I'm looking forward to giving the
talk so you've already had an
introduction I am an epidemiologist by
training and at the moment I do a lot of
critical appraisal of studies when we're
doing systematic reviews trying to
decide what should we include in our
body of work when we're doing that
analysis so what I wanted to do was
start off with just giving you the
agenda of what we're going to talk about
and i should say ahead of time i have a
little bit of a sore throat so every so
often i'm going to reach for my cup of
tea so we'll talk about what's critical
appraisal then we're going to make sure
we differentiate between critical
appraisal and comprehensive reporting
which are two very related but often
confused aspects of critical appraisal
then we're going to get into some
specifics of actually walking through
how to critically appraise a paper
focusing particularly on laboratory
animal models and the way we're going to
do that is talk about the risk of bias
remains and I'm not sure how familiar
people are with the risk of bias domain
for what it is is a stylized way of
thinking about critical appraisal so
that's the agenda that we're going to
have and we're going to start off with
talking about a discussion of critical
appraisal so just to be familiar with
some of the synonyms so critical
appraisal is a very old term and it's
been around long since i started
teaching critical appraisal one of the
things about critical appraisal i think
is that it's always been a bit of a
mystery and you know professors decide
not to include a paper in a review or
they dismiss the paper and they really
articulate exactly the rationale wyd
study is considered to be not of good
evidentiary value and should be
dismissed and so critical appraisal can
seem almost like a black box one of the
other difficulties of problems with
critical appraisal editors it is often a
judgment and many scientists especially
early in their career are really
uncomfortable with the idea of making
a judgment they would like to have a
fact-based approach and unfortunately
critical appraisal is often a judgment
and there's no getting away from it but
what we would like is for the process or
the rationale for our phrasal she become
more transparent because often I think
historically it has not been so here
what I've got is a couple of synonyms
for critical appraisal that we should be
aware of the term quality assessment is
one that's been used more frequently in
the systematic review arena and it's an
older term if you know if you think that
systematic reviews have been around in
the clinical sciences for maybe 20 25
years people used to do quality
assessment um that's a very judgment
Laden term that became quite unpopular
so you will see that but it's becoming
less used because of the value judgment
that said that people found it offensive
that a paper was considered to be low
quality are the same with validity
assessment is a term you might use and I
tend to use the word risk of bias
assessment um but I still I think
they're all synonyms just so you're
aware that these things are very much
the same so what it is is an assessment
of the validity of the results of a
study based on how the study was
conducted so you look at how the study
was conducted and you try to assess how
valid are the results and what's also
important is you should make sure that
if you're assessing a bias which we'll
discuss it is do you think it's going to
have a huge impact it was all studies
have some imperfection right so we're
not looking for perfect what we're
looking for is egregious biases that we
think are really going to change the
entrance and then what we have to think
about is what the direction of inference
is so for example are we more likely to
reject the null hypothesis because of
the way the study was convicted
conducted or I'll
less likely because those things make a
difference as we're assessing them so
why do we have to do critical appraisal
in the first place where we have to do
critical appraisal because not all
studies are of equal value with respect
to the decision we're trying to make so
some studies yeah when we read a study
we're trying to decide what we do with
this information and maybe we're
deciding to approve a drug maybe we're
deciding to do the next process are the
next study test the next hypothesis in
the scientific process and normal
studies are created equal and we want to
make the best decision we can and
therefore we would like to use unbiased
we'd like to use unbiased answers but
really what we probably like to use is
less biased answers it's an essential
part of the scientific process and as I
mentioned earlier and I've made this
point here often i think previously um
critical appraisal has been potentially
very informal and sometimes it's kind of
seemed arbitrary so we'd like to move
away from that approach and you know by
the end of the talk what we'd like you
to have is one tool and there are others
are available that you can use to
systematically critically appraise a
study and then make your judgment and
then also have your rationale for your
judgment so next thing I want to talk
about is the difference between critical
appraisal and comprehensive reporting
because I know there's been some work on
comprehensive reporting and I think
tomorrow you're gonna hear from Malcolm
and perhaps even today but mother's
talking about how important a
comprehensive reporting is so let's talk
about what critical appraisal is not so
critical appraisal is not the same as
assessing whether a study is
comprehensively in fourth reported um
you'd be aware I'm sure that there are
several guidelines available to and I've
got a few here the arrived guidelines
and also
the guidelines from the National
Research Council on how to report the
conduct and the results of an animal
experiments and these guidelines are a
critical a really key part of critical
appraisal because we need comprehensive
reporting we need to know what people
did and we need to know what people
found to be able to critically appraise
however there one thing I do see is
sometimes people use as figuratively
arrive guidelines which is a checklist
of you know these are the things that
you should report and people sometimes
use those as a critical appraisal tool
so a study that might as they count up
how many of the arrive guideline items
are reported now that does not equate to
critical appraisal of course we'd like
to have all the items on the checklist
but just because an iphone report a
study reports all the items on the grip
on the arrive checklist doesn't mean it
was has a low bias the authors might
have done dreadful things they're just
very honest about it right they might
have used a terrible approach to the
study but they're very honest about it
so you should not equate comprehensive
reporting with critical appraisal
although we need comprehensive reporting
so one of the things about these
critical or praised the recording
checklists is usually what you're doing
is you're reporting you're assessing
whether the presence or absence of
something being reported if that doesn't
necessarily imply bias so let's have a
look here here's an example of some text
somebody might write so on this slide
what we have is a piece of text somebody
might have written and it'll say animals
eligible for the study were randomized
to treatment group using a random number
allocation so I assume by today there's
been several discussions about the
importance of randomization
um for reducing selection bias so if we
were using something like the arrived
guidelines we would say that yes check
the box the authors did report
randomization however let's just have a
look you see the blue box what I have is
some baseline data about that study so
you'll see that I have the treated group
and there are six animals in that group
and I have the untreated group and there
are 67 animals in that group so let's
just imagine this is the two are
parallel study so it's an experimental
study and it's got two arms who treated
in the untreated now what we have here
is the baseline distribution of sex at
the beginning of the study and what you
can see here is that they have five
these investigators ended up even though
using random allocation with five males
in one group and two in the other group
so if we thought that the males were a
potential confounder as and they were
associated with the outcome then we
might say that actually based on this
baseline data we have the potential for
a selection bias but both of these are
examples of good reporting so the
authors reported that they did
randomized and they used to number a
random number generator to do it so we
know that there's a check for a
checklist and here the authors have
reported baseline demographics of the
two treatment groups so if we were using
something like the arrive checklist we
would give this a check for our
reporting approach to allocation we'd
give it a check for reporting our
baseline demographics but from a
critical appraisal point of view we're
probably going to reach the conclusion
that there's a high risk of bias if sex
is associated with the outcome because
we
be able to tell if the outcome is cause
if any difference we see between boobs
won't be able to tell if that that's
because they were treated or because the
majority of them are now so again here's
another example I think this is a really
critical point so I'm going to make it a
few times just because someone required
something and they get a check in a
reporting guideline does not mean that
it's a low risk of bias so for example
here we have the authors have reported
as they should how they identify the
animals and so you can see here the
animals were with the treatment were
identified with markers and it might be
something along these lines that I have
the sheet that they've got an identifier
or you see the mice have a different
identifiers now first of all that's
going to be a check for the arrived
guidelines did they did the authors tell
you about the approach to identifying
the animals now the next step which is
critical appraisal of whether that's
important right is there a high risk of
bias he's actually going to be dependent
upon something completely different so
for example let's just say the outcome
but our blue box there and I'm
presenting the data again and instead of
this time reporting the baseline data as
I did when I reported previously now
I've got the outcome so let's say the
outcome is mortality now mortality is an
outcome that's fairly hard to miss
specify most times it's quite obvious if
an animal is dead and it's quite obvious
in the animals alive and so the fact
that you know that a mouse has a red dot
on its head or a blue stripe on its back
is not likely to introduce a bias again
the difference between a checkbox for
comprehensive reporting and critical
appraisal now the other thing I want to
point out here that's different between
critical appraisal and comprehensive
reporting and this is just the general
issue is that when we are looking at
comprehensive reporting there are a lot
comprehensive reporting guidelines as I
pointed up to and the truth is that
reporting guidelines are much easier to
produce and disseminate then critical of
phrase guidelines and the reason for
that is reporting guidelines are usually
about a particular type of question for
example the investigators might be
asking about an intervention or no so
they want to know whether this
particular drug has an effect on an
outcome and it doesn't matter what the
drug isn't it doesn't want matter what
the outcome is the study design is
almost certainly going to be the same
usually a no it's a two arm parallel
design or a factorial design but it's
still parallel or crossover design but
this generally the design is the same
and we know how to conduct that design
to reduce bias usually quite well and
that goes across all disciplines so
comprehensive reporting guidelines tend
to be about a particular study so for
example about an experiment you know
parallel experiment or randomized
control trial or they might you might
get comprehensive reporting guidelines
for how to evaluate a diagnostic test on
the other hand when you get to
critically appraising you'll find a lot
fewer because critical appraisal usually
requires expertise that is
topic-specific because you need to know
very much we need to know what factors
are associated with the outcome because
if we look back here at our two groups
what we need to know is what factors
could differ between the groups that
could affect the outcome and that often
requires in-depth knowledge about the
outcome and in-depth knowledge about the
treatments and therefore usually if
you're doing critical appraisal you have
to design you have to take the domains
that we're talking about and think
how they apply to the West oh so that's
another difference between critical
appraisal and comprehensive reporting
and that for that reason you know this
comment that I've got here is that
critical appraisals need topic specific
expertise and therefore there are very
few canned critical appraisal tools you
need Lee need to have to go and identify
what are the potential confounders how
could somebody misclassify this you need
to know what are the confounders you
also need to know for example for the
outcome how are you going to measure the
outcome in this particular area and how
can that go wrong and so just to make
the final point against about this this
has continued this example that we had
about the comprehensive reporting and
how you need expertise for critical
appraisal so now what I've got I've got
the comprehensive reporting so the
authors have told us about how they
identify the animals now but two
outcomes I've got mortality and as we've
mentioned mortality it's going to be
difficult to miss classify that right
but on the other hand if I'm studying a
different outcome perhaps in this group
of animals I am studying companionship
behavior which is a very subjective
outcome so for that situation I probably
need an expert to tell me how can I
accurately measure that and how can that
be calling injured so that when I read
the papers I can assess whether the
authors have an accurate measure of
companionship behavior or do they have a
poor measure of companionship behavior
because that will affect my critical
appraisal so now I want to talk about
the actual components of critical
appraisal and and how we're going to do
it and we're going to start off by
talking very quickly about external
validity
then moving rapidly on to internal
validity because internal validity is
what matters but we should mention the
concept of external validity especially
with respect to experimental animals
external validity is often sometimes
called generalizability although there
are other terms there are other uses for
the word generalizability so it can be
problematic to use that term so external
validity is about who you can
extrapolate the results of the study too
and the problem it's really hard to
critically appraise that because even
extrapolate the results to is in the eye
of the beholder and we know that in
laboratory animal experiments sometimes
we feel that the results of the findings
can be extrapolated to two humans and
that's why we do laboratory animal
models because we think that they're a
good model of behavior or outcomes in
humans or perhaps were more interested
in extrapolating to the the next
population the next research population
so external validity is a judgment call
and we're not going to spend much more
time on it what we're interested in
mainly the incredible appraisal is
internal validity which is due the
results of this study represent what
actually happened in the population that
the source population in in laboratory
animals the idea of a source population
is difficult to understand so I think a
more pragmatic approach to thinking
about internal validity is are the
results of the finding valid or were
they influenced by the way the study was
conducted so let's just talk more about
internal validity so this is the one
that we're really interested in now I
should point out that we're really
interested in internal validity because
if the results of this
you do not represent what happens in
mice generally so for example if you do
a study on Thorson minus 20 of them and
those results cannot be even
extrapolated to other doors and minds or
your colony or whoever they came from
then they they're really pointless right
there's not much you can do with them up
with that so external validity is a moot
point so we always spend our time
initially thinking about internal
validity and then we make some
assessment about external is it so just
a little bit of a refresher hopefully
this is not too basic but first of all
what i mean by the results so I'm
anything quantitatively so let's just
start here we've got two groups of mice
and we've got the group of mice who are
bounded by the blue box right so that's
these guys they're receiving one
treatment and then we've got another
group of mice that are receiving
whatever's in the red treatment right so
what we want to do is measure our
outcome and here you can see that I have
a categorical outcome and what it does
is something makes the post go go dark
and get pink is so you can see the
outcome occurred in two of the ten miles
here and four of the ten minus over here
so this is really basic stuff although I
managed to get it wrong so how am I
going to summarize the results with one
number and there are two ways I'm going
to do that one is I could do the risk
difference I'm just going to subtract
them so the risk of getting pinky is in
the red group is 40 the risk of getting
pink is in the blue group is 20 and you
can see I've got a type over here the
difference should actually be 20 that's
one way I can get one number to describe
the results of my study now the other
way I could do it is i could just
calculate the ratio of voters and as an
aside generally when we have categorical
outcomes like this so this is a your
inner category are we usually prefer to
summarize the results are using a ratio
right so here I've got 20 / 10 you've
got a risk ratio to which says you're
twice as likely to get our pink ears if
you're in the red group in the blue
group so oh why do we just as an aside
why do we do it with the ratio I know
because we don't want the outcome to
depended upon the prevalence so here
what I've got here is the same
experiment it's of an output a larger
sample size and I have the same number
of outcomes so you can see here I've got
2 out of 15 and four out of 15 now if i
calculate the risk difference now the
risk difference is 13 whereas before it
was 20 so the same intervention
different number right if I use the risk
ratio then I get 26 / 13 and I'm still
able to say the red treatment double the
risk of getting blue pink is so we'd
like to have what I numbers that are
called generalizable and that's one of
the reasons why I prefer not to use were
generalizable for external validity your
risk ratio is a number that should work
across populations well what we're
really interested in critical appraisal
is did the observed ratio that risk
ratio there are two or the risk
difference that of 13 did it arise
because of the treatment did I get that
too because of the treatment it arise
because of systematic fires something I
did incorrectly in the study or did it
arise because of imprecision and that's
basically critical appraisal
international so now now if you want to
think about that little bit more
pragmatically the other way to think
about it is what is the potential for
any factors other than the treatment to
have influenced that too to give us a
tube is there something else other than
the treatment because what we'd like it
to be is the treatment because that's
what we want to make him fitted out and
that is the idea of critical afraid note
so what are the ways that other factors
could make it not the treatment so there
are two ways that this can happen one is
in precision we know that every
experiments result is just a random
event right so if we have a very small
experiment we have a much higher
potential for random Europe and so one
reason that we might have got a two when
the real number was one could be just
the way we sampled we just took a small
cell now we can solve in position by
seneca funds now i just want to explain
why small sample sizes leads to the
potential to get a larger cute of a more
emphasized estimate and the example I'm
going to use is not actually an
invention i'm going to imagine that we
are interested in estimating the number
of women at the institution at which you
work and i'm thinking about 26 people so
you know we might have 26 institutions
and we would like to estimate what is
the proportion of women so that's our
result so if i sent you all out to
sample at yon your institution and you
could take a random sample so you put a
sampling frame that has all the people
at the institution but i only let you
select three people now when you do that
you have the potential to get four
different numbers you can get an
estimate of zero to six thirty-three
percent 66 and 100 feet and i think most
of us would think that let's just
imagine that the prevalence is actually
50 busy most of us would think that if
we only took three that there is
actually a chance that we would get zero
women in our sample and there is
actually a chance that we would get
three women in our sample so those
extreme values there we go those
extreme values are possible right it's
very impress ice because it's extremely
unlikely that any of us work at the
institution where there are 0 woman or a
hundred percent now on the other hand if
I told you look you don't have to take
three you can take 30 samples now the
chances that you will get zero women out
of 30 population that has 15 17 very
very sick and the same for a hundred so
your potential for imprecision decreases
as yourself or photos put your
variations and of course if i said to
you can take 300 Win 300 randomly
selected faculty or whatever from your
is then the chances that you'll get zero
is almost invisible so you can solve
precision by increasing examples you
should always remember that one reason
that you could get this too is just it's
a random event and you've just sampled a
randomly rare group of elements which is
why we want replication right because
unless we have replication we really
don't know how random that event is we
rely on replication to help us
understand to reduce the potential for a
random event so the two things that we
reduce in precision are increasing your
sample size but of course that's the
basis for meta-analysis is replicating
we see people do a study over and over
again and we get the same finding and we
start to think that must be the result
so the other reason that we can get our
the wrong number is because of
systematic errors she says systematic
errors are errors that it doesn't matter
what you do with the sample size you're
not going to correct the problem the
classic example of a systematic error is
the easiest to understand is imagine
that I'm interested in measuring the
length of rats tails for whatever reason
and so imagine this is my ruler and I
think that it is 10-7
as long but it turns out that it's
actually nine point five centimeters on
now that means that it doesn't matter
whether I measure the tales of ten mice
or a hundred votes I am systematically
going to underestimate the length of my
population and so that's a systematic
error and it doesn't matter what I do
about it it's going to happen and its
respective of sample size okay so we're
going to focus on internal bias internal
validity and now we're going to walk our
way through what are the ways that we
can think about the factors that could
make differences in the group's occur
other than the tree and I think this is
what I really like about this you know
this approach to risk of bias is that it
gives you a set of factors to consider
very explicitly you know in truth many
many people are already using these they
just don't have a name attached to them
and I think this you know approach to
mr. by assessment it is a real step
forward I would point out that the
nomenclature for bias varies but the one
that I'm using is based on the Cochrane
group who do systematic reviews in human
health of intervention studies
particularly randomized controlled
trials in humans and the terminology
that I use is theirs and the reason that
we use theirs rather than others because
there's an epidemiologist to Munich
slightly different terms but everything
for risk of bias is because in animal
experimentation the designs that you use
to assess interventions or exposures are
very similar to the designs used to
assess interventions and frossians in
people so it's you know that the
parallel intervention the experiment or
the crossover design or factorial design
if you're interested in more than you're
interested in interaction so because of
the similarity between the assessment of
interventions in people and the
assessment
interventions and frozen sea animals it
makes sense to use a nomenclature that
the Cochrane our group meetings and this
is that this is that so now what we are
to do is work through these and we're
going to start off with probably the
weather the easiest to understand and
that is selection bias so what we're
looking at now is trying to think of
going back to that first question it
said what are the factors that could
have explained by 2 as if other than the
treatment and this is them one factor
could be selection blinds one factor
could be performance buyers detection by
us attrition buyers reporting buyers
I've already talked a little bit about
random error and at the end I'm going to
talk just quickly about multiplicity so
let's talk about selection bias as a
factor that could have caused me to see
a 2 when it wasn't actually at you so
the way that we're going to do this is
we're going to start off we're going to
have an example and I'm you're just
going to illustrate some of these are
really egregious and to sort of really
drive home the point of how this could
provide an alternative explanation for
the result the risk ratio to just let me
have a cup of tea okay so selection bias
so here I've got a quote there in blue
and what I've said that my simmer study
were allocated to the treatment group by
sex so treatment consisted of female
mice and treatment B consisted of male 1
so obviously the way that the
investigators selected the animals for
the treating these based on sex now we
might think that that has the potential
to cause the groups to be different with
respect to our outcome and that's
actually the critical factor here what
you need to know is
if the factor that you're worried about
is whether there's another factor at the
baseline so when you allocated animals
to prove or when you're reading a paper
and you talk they're talking about how
to a litter hated animals to the group
is there another factor at the baseline
no and by based on I made at the
beginning of the study that could be
related to the outcome that might
explain the result so here we go we've
got this experiment again and but this
time what I'm going to do is I'm going
to you look at the next slide and
believe it or not these five mice here
is five most here they're going to get
fat and these two mice here they're
going to get fat too so our outcome is
going to be weight gain over this period
of this experiment and so believe it or
not these mice get fatter and what you
can see is what look better go they got
fatter so we've finished our experiment
and so we've got a few mice that gained
weight in these group and you can see a
few mice that gained weight in this
group and of course it wouldn't be
surprising but our outcome with you
weight gain and so we would some all
these up and get the average weight gain
fear some all these I can get the
average weight down here and then we
would because this is a continuous
outcome we're probably going to subtract
them not take the ratio and so we're
going to say that the way we're going to
summarize the result is that the mean
difference in the group is 20 grand so
here's the meat in this group here's the
men in this group and the difference is
20 grand and what we'd like to do is
attributed to grams to the treatment so
we'd say getting the blue treatment
major gain an extra 20 grand now if I
were to tell you at the baseline that
instead I didn't use I don't have sex
evenly distributed across the group so
if you look here each of the animals
that in one of these little boxes if I
want to
tell you that they would mail then you
might say hang on a second there's a lot
more males in this group there are in
this group we would expect males to have
higher levels of game then you would say
that another reason that I might have
seen these 20 grams of difference is not
the treatment but maybe it's the sex
distribution and so it's another factor
so the factor that you're interested in
is sex you think that sex is associated
with the outcome and the issue is how
did you select the animals to get into
the state so whatever approach was used
here didn't balance this confounded the
third factor that's associated with the
outcome evenly so you're looking for a
selection bias what you're looking for
the bias occurs because of the way
selected the animals into the study now
other groups comparable such that the
observed difference is attributable to
the treatment rather than the confounder
and the truth is in this example you
can't tell and the answer is likely no
it's quite possible that the difference
that we saw is because of sex not the
treatment now when this is not a study
design lecture but of course it's worth
talking about how one avoid study by a
selection bones and what you're looking
for in a paper to try to say well is
this study likely to have a selection
bias or not and the most important
factor is randomization now one of the
things that's problematic with
randomization is that when you have
small sample sizes it is quite difficult
to ensure that not known confounders an
unknown confounders are evenly balanced
so you would be looking to see if
studies randomized but
if you had an important confounder like
this like sex it's quite possible even
if you randomize with such a small study
that you could end up with this sort of
uneven distribution so what you might
also look for is what's called block
randomization or stratification in which
case what you'd look for is for people
to say well I'm going to take all 10
males and I'm going to within those 10
miles i'm going to randomize the
treatment and then i'm going to take all
10 female and i'm going to randomize the
treatment and that way i'll make sure
that the males and the females are
evenly distributed so what you'll be
looking for is things like randomization
you'll also be looking for the sample
size because if you've got a thousand
mice then you don't need to block
randomized it's likely that you'll
evenly distribute the confounders if
you've already got a very small study
then you'll be wanting to know did they
do anything extra in the paper to
control for confounders like blocking or
stratifying the other thing you'll be
looking for it for critically appraising
is for them to record baseline
demographic remember back at the
beginning I showed you a study that said
hey at the beginning I had five minutes
that were male in one group of one in
another that reporting of the
demographics of the mice with respective
important confounded is something that
you're hoping that they have recorded
and they've recorded comprehensible so
when you're critically appraising what
you're looking for is to that the two
groups are comparable and where you'll
find that information is by looking for
the allocation approach is a randomized
is a block randomized looking at the
sample size to the side that they need
to do something extra control for the
confounders and you're looking for them
to report the demographic information
now one of the things i would say that
often not considered very well in
experimental studies is that restriction
is one of the most common ways of a very
scary
control for confounding so if I would go
back here and I said I only studied male
mice then clearly I'm not going to get
confounded by sex now of course can't do
that anymore we can expect agenda but
with respect to sex but there are
restriction is a really common way and
effective way that laboratory animal
studies control for selection bias they
just exclude them I'm going to have
animals of the same age to the same
genetic line so that's the other thing
that you should look at is how much
variation do you think can happen in
this study populations we've got so the
next one I want to talk about is
performance bias so performance bias
doesn't refer to at the beginning
because performance buyers it so we
talked about selection bias which is at
the beginning you know are the animals
even with respect to a beginning of the
study well now we're talking about
performance buyers and that is sort of
over the period of time of the conduct
of study were there systematic
differences in the care of the animals
or the housing that could have created
the difference so think of performance
by ourselves across the hot you know for
the length of the study and not have a
really quite no really simple example
here mice and the infected through were
housed in the newer bell three isolation
facility and individual pages however is
there is no biological need and to
reduce costs the untreated control minus
the house in two group pages in it older
blt facility now clearly there's a
possibility that the difference between
the two groups especially in weight gain
if you go back to my example previously
might be attributable to a the
difference in facility and be the
difference in housing and so as I said
again what you're saying now is now tell
me about the whole conduct of the study
and is there anything in that time
period that could have caused
differences so when you're reading a
paper what you want to know is were they
house the same
they cared for the same way and I should
point out so there you know in animal
studies are really looking at two things
the housing the things those aspects and
the arrived guidelines sort of see tell
us about that the other thing we're
looking for which may only be not
relevant depending upon the topic and
hence its topic-specific is whether the
caregivers who are making the decisions
about additional care or rations etc are
aware of the animals group so that's an
issue of blinding so I do want to point
out that blinding use a tool that we use
to prevent bias but we shouldn't use the
word single triple and double in animal
experiments I would encourage you to
look for papers or in your own writing
to talk about what was blinded so if you
think about biases one bias is
performing science and what you like is
for the caregivers to care for the truth
the two treatment groups evenly so you
should blind the caregivers to the
status of the other so as I said
performance bias is about whether over
the period of time the way that you
cared for the animals they were housed
could have caused the difference and in
my example it could have caused a
difference awakening what you're looking
for is that sort of information which
should be in the methods and materials
the next sort of buyers is detection
buyers this is the one that people are
fight familiar with so detection bias
refers to the end of the study as in now
you're measuring the outcome so we
talked about selection bias which is at
the beginning of the baseline
performance plans which is across the
whole edge of the whole study in the
care and now we're talking about
detection bonds and I've got an example
here the cages of mice in the group
treated with a fantastic new lot drug
were labeled with the term fantastic
drug and the cages of the moster did not
receive the treatment were labeled with
all drugged and each day star feeding
the mice were asked to describe how
active the most we're on a scale of one
to five
so here what we're doing is we're
assessing the outcome so this is the end
result and clearly because what we're
doing is measuring the outcome and there
is likely to be a bias in the way we're
measuring the countdown because in this
example the people who are measuring the
outcome know the animals treatment group
so here is another spot where we blind
now previously we blinded to prevent
performance bikes now we're blinding to
prevent detection bar because we want
the outcome to be obsessed without
knowledge of the treatment so again this
comes back to this issue of the
difference between comprehensive
reporting and bias assistance so
blinding is something that people can
record but it doesn't necessarily mean
that the study is or even flying right
so detection bias occurs when there are
systematic differences between treatment
groups in the way the outcome is is set
now to decide if this detection bias
you're going to have to have
comprehensive reporting about how the
outcome is measured and information
about for whining another bias that we
see that's a little bit harder to
understand is attrition bias and it's
probably best understood by looking at
this example attrition bias is lost to
follow-up so you lose animals in the
study now in human health is hugely
important because people can choose to
leave a study so there's voluntary
attrition I get fed up with the study or
there's involuntary attrition people die
from competing forces so of course
there's no voluntary attrition bias in
animal studies it's all involuntary but
here's an example so for example here
we've got 24 animals were allocated to
two treatment groups so we know we've
got 12 per group and what you can see
here is the average weight of the mice
in one group was 2.5 grams and N equals
7 and then it's 2.4 in the other but n
is equal to 12 so we can see that we've
lost five animals and so the question is
really if we've lost five animals is it
really valid to be comparing these and
what was the result of those five
animals if we imagine I know try and
draw this if I can that we had a really
bi modal what I don't think that's going
to work yeah nope that's not going to
work with my bother with that so every
match we had a really bi modal treatment
so the first group there were one group
of animals that were really healthy and
another group that were really unwell
and they actually reached a weight-loss
point where we had to euthanize them so
in truth if they'd have been allowed to
survive they would have had a very low
weight so we've removed them from the
study for valid ethical reasons so now
what we're comparing Oh me is is the
survivors in treatment group the first
treatment group and those survivors
might not have a weight that's
representative of everybody who was in
the study and so that's an attrition
bias I know you got Johnny to a
statistician about what's the outcome
you should be measuring it's probably
the best way to think about attrition
violence in this example survival would
probably have been a more appropriate
outcome than average weight gain because
in the in the first group five animals
didn't survive to the enemy and last but
not least of the systematic biases one
that we should watch out for is
reporting bonus and the way that we see
this can be quite difficult because
again we're we're hoping the people
report comprehensively and if they don't
we can't assess this we can see in this
example is that the authors have
recorded that they've assessed the
weights of liver kidney frames clean and
alums so that's what they measured their
work
were they measured but when the results
were read they'd already given us the
results for the kidneys so so there's a
difference in the kidney ways and that
might be interesting but there's no
information about the brain is cleaning
the lungs and so this gives the
impression that there might be a big
difference but if we brain the spleen
and alums are actually not different
then maybe that is really important to
us because we said that four of the
organs had no difference out of 5 might
be more meaningful to us than just
asleep so this would be problematic from
our reporting bias point of view because
it seems like the author's might be
cherry picking the results and choosing
to make all the inference will on the
kidneys and not the other information
now of course there's nothing we can do
about that except but we might give the
study less value you might say well it
seems like some results are key and
nothing you can do about it but it might
give us confidence in the overall
entrance of the authors of making I've
already talked about the potential for
random error and the fact that the
bigger the sample size the less
likelihood that you have a random error
I also do want to point out that when we
look at the p-value that gives us the
probability of observing a difference as
big as we saw all bigger under the null
hypothesis that the results the same and
when as you can see here we have an
exact p-value and you can see wow it's
it's really unlikely that we would have
seen this result is 90 versus 10 so is
that what it is quite a rare result so
it's either a big effect or we've got a
really rare result on the other hand
when p.m. 0 when authors report this way
just the p-value is less than point 05
we really cannot make any judgment at
just how rare this result was in this
example you could have done the data you
now assess yourself but not normally
so maybe the key values 2006 or point 0
for 9 less than point eight five you
know maybe we think well that's not that
rare no like if it Queen 049 that means
it basically happens one in 20 times
that's not that rare you know like get
to die one in 36 times if we don't think
that's an incredibly rare of it so you
know you should you should i hope that
authors report comprehensively and you
can assess them and then i want to talk
about multiple testing and you should
think about when you're critically
appraising papers multiple testing
multiple tests and we know we're doing
hypothesis tests and we know that if we
have say a point p value of 105 that
means that we would reject the null
hypothesis when it's true one in 20
times so if you just do a ton of tests
then you know you're likely to end up
with fun artistically significant
results just out of dumb life so here we
have an example where we've got three
treatment groups we've got wet weight
throw away and surface area for a
plethora of ordnance and we're going to
do all possible comparison and it turns
out that this actually ends up being 63
different hypotheses this so really you
expect some to be significant just by
random chance and so when you're looking
at a paper and it's got just its kind of
outcome and only a few of them is
significant you might think wow these
are they were potentially just random so
what to do about multiple testing is a
whole two hour-long lecture in in
experimental studies but you should
seriously think about you know if
they're testing lots of outcomes and
devoted out a few things significant
maybe it's just random error one of the
problems with this is that people comes
back to recording buyers if the authors
don't tell you that they tested 63
things they only tell you about three or
four
and then they report the results of
those three or four then you can't
assess the impact of multiplicity which
comes back to many of issues of
reproducible reporting and comprehensive
reporting so they're all the ways that
you can assess bias and I'm going to
have to rub up because I've running out
of time but in the end what I want to
say is that you do have to reach a
conclusion and what we suggest is that
you look through the paper for your
reading and you petition out the sources
of violence and you decide what you're
going to consider to be low risk of bias
high risk of bias and try not to use
unclear and I'm afraid to say that there
is no way to avoid making a judgment
however it's what we've always done but
now people are asking you to articulate
why did you make that judgment so you
should say whether it's a lower risk of
bias or a high risk of fires and it's
not possible to avoid judgment just can
have to do it do avoid giving scores do
not add them up and say a paper has five
pies and to lowes avoid that because you
might have what you're giving is exactly
equal value to each source of bias and
that's not might not be appropriate for
example maybe the deflection bias is an
absolutely egregious issue and makes the
whole study invalid and everything else
is fine but if you summed it up that's
study round to get a point of one there
we go first you might have another study
that has you know two other sources of
buyers it has a multiplicity problem but
you're not that worried about it so they
know they might have a multiplicity
problem in one study and detection
buyers in another study you really think
the deflection buyers issue is
problematic but if you some
you're going to give them the same score
and that's not perfect so you know
manuscripts would go through you know
how you would answer these questions and
give it a high and low value you're also
point out where you might look at a
paper to find that information and then
we give you an example of how to do it
but I'm afraid to say that in the end
critical appraisal is always that
judgment however here we enable you to
petition up into these the bias areas
that I've discussed I'll finish up now
and point out that we have a manuscript
that is freely available that goes
through these topics and at the end and
has that checklist um and so I would
encourage you to look at this if you're
thinking about critically appraising for
well there's also another one by the
circle group which is called risk of
bias and animal experiments it's very
very similar but all of them now try to
focus on petitioning how you critically
appraise based on these different
aspects of buyers and trying to
articulate how you reach decision of
whether it was a high-risk revise and a
low-risk advice and nothing you do is
going to get you away from having to
make a judgment afraid thanks very much
for your time and I'm not trying to
climb for questions and if we do have
any we will have to answer them
afterwards I'll hand back over well
thank you and dr. O'Connor for that very
informative presentation um we certainly
learned a lot from that so it's not time
for the QA if you have a question that
you'd like to ask dr. O'Connor please do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for so
we have one question
burnet and the question is how do you
conclude the results if we face health
issues and control groups of the
experiment ah well thanks for that I
thanks for that question you know
unfortunately there's almost no solution
to this problem um I what I'm assuming
is the issue is that you've got this
imagine you've got a two-armed parallel
design and one of them is a control
group and then you have health issues in
that group for example maybe some of
them well we've got health issues and so
maybe they die and that's one of your
outcomes or maybe they've lost weight
now with those health issues are
unrelated to thee to the outcome I
there's really nothing you can do about
that and I think we're actually now I
think about it I think this all depends
on what your outcome use so if your
outcome is going to be affected by
health issue so for example your outcome
is weight gain and you think that those
health issues are unrelated to the
treatment then it's going to be
confounded on the other hand if you
think the health issues are actually
part of the treatment effect then you
shouldn't have any problems so really it
depends on whether you think those
health issues are part of the treatment
effect or not and so and that would
depend on your outcome oh okay and we
have time for another question um and
Giuliana asked what statistical test is
appropriate when you have only n of
three animals per group and multiple
groups okay so I so the question was
what's the statistical test is
appropriate so um the answer to that is
mr. chase
test that you would choose is not
necessarily rated based on the number of
animals it's based on the type of
outcome you have so if you have a
continuous outcome then you're going to
trying to do something like a t-test if
you have a categorical outcomes such as
whether the animals died or not then
you're going to be looking at doing
something like the chi-square test the
issue that you have here of N equals 2 3
is that you almost have no power to you
take any difference doesn't matter
whether it's a continuous outcome or a
categorical outcome so the statistical
test of choice is based on the nature of
the outcome whether you'd have any power
to detect the difference when n is 3
depends on the variation and it's going
to be rare and multiple groups
truthfully if you say when I talked
about the t-test that's a comparison of
two groups a very simple comparison of
two groups if you have multiple groups
so for example you have treatment a B
and C so you're still the test that you
pick is going to be based on the nature
of the outcome so for example it if it's
continuous you're probably going to pick
something like an ANOVA or you might use
regression or something I'm not a not a
degree an aggression too broad but if
you've got a categorical outcome you're
still probably going to use some sort of
chi squared test but again the issue of
the N equals 3 is not the factor that
enables you to decide what statistical
test you're going to do that's dependent
on the nature of the outcome that your
bedroom but any of course three means
always going to have no power to detect
a difference I hope that answers that
question
okay I think that's all the time we have
now for questions so i would like to
once again thank dr. Cotter for
presentation do you have any final
comments first no thanks very much as i
said one of the sad things about
critical appraisal is it still ends up
being a judgment but if we can make
those judgments transparent and
comprehensive and more systematic i
think we'll move the area of critical
appraisal will progress a great deal
well thank you once again dr. O'Connor
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing until August of
2016 you will receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast is
available for replay please feel free to
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us I would hope to see you
again soon bye bye